The Joe Rogan experience.
Siberia is always been an interesting place in Russia.
No,
no,
no.
Have you,
did you do up there?
1990?
Yeah.
Uh,
right before communism fell.
I was there for three weeks.
Well before communism fell off was a in power.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Uh,
it was the spy.
Yep.
Privy of the cat dealer.
You'll get pulling my Abdul's though.
Wow.
That's pretty good.
Would you say I said hello?
Uh,
I don't understand.
Please and thank you.
That's just the words I remember.
Uh,
it was just program founded by Dwight d Eisenhower in the four days of the,
it's called people to people where the,
they send the youth of America to other countries to hang out with that youth to
promote world peace.
And that's all it is.
And certain kids from high schools are selected and they go,
you got to Washington DC first for three,
you know,
for three days.
They,
they,
they debrief you and then you go to another country and ours was Russia.
It was awesome.
I had a great time.
Wow.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
I told Bert Kreischer that too.
You know,
cause he has the whole machine story.
I said,
I feel like I can't tell my Russian story because you've,
you've owned it so much with your machines toy that if I do anything about this
that it's going to look like [inaudible] you too,
Huh?
Yeah.
You got in Russia story do you should tell it.
People want to hear it.
They'll understand.
They don't think you're,
I kind of got in trouble because I was trading illegally on the black market
over there will be done on purpose.
I didn't know is doing it.
Um,
because you as look full story right.
Cause a cop and like tell me more.
That's kind of what happened.
This dude I was talking to,
it was after like a function that we were at,
you know,
where they,
you would go to the,
some,
some towns I'm village and they'd come and they'd greet you with bread and salt
and they would dance around and then you would just eat with them and hang out
or whatever.
And,
um,
so I was just talking to this kid,
you know,
and they speak perfect English,
we're the ones that don't speak Russian.
So this kid is trying to teach me Russian cuss words and I thought he's pretty
cool.
It's before the Internet,
you know.
So I have a bunch of these ink pans that my mom gave me from the phone company
where she works.
She goes,
just give them,
make pants.
They live anything with English,
riding on it,
anything American,
they're going to love it.
Bubblegum,
jeans,
ink pens.
So I was like,
yeah,
dude,
let's,
uh,
let's be pen pals.
So exchanging addresses,
you know,
like,
oh,
keep in touch with you,
why not?
And I give him a pen and it gives me his address.
And what I don't know is this dude's already kind of in trouble with cops over
there for trading illegally on the black market.
I had no idea.
And this cop just grabbed both of us,
the drags us into the hotel and no one saw me from my group get grabbed by the
way,
because I was off doing my own little thing that this dude,
right,
uh,
learning Russian customers.
So I'd go into his office in this hotel and they're just cussing each other in
Russian.
And I don't know what the hell is going on.
I'm like,
dude,
what is this?
Am I a big trouble here?
I mean,
you know,
he goes,
if this little shits,
I'm not to worry about that.
This is bullshit.
Then they scream some more.
Now the cop doesn't speak English.
And so he's basically my translator disguise to the cop.
I'm like,
Hey man,
I'm with this group.
You know,
I don't know what's going on.
And so he kicks that kid out,
the Russian comp,
and now it's just me and this Russian cop.
And I'm looking at him and he's looking at me and he looks at my bag with all
these ink pens and he's like,
he goes like this.
He's like,
what was,
you know,
let me see.
You know,
I'll call you want a pen.
So I handed him a pen and he looks at it.
Is that going to cool?
It puts it in his desk and it goes away and it comes back with this big ass
Russian pendant,
sickle and hammer thing with wings coming out of pretty cool looking thing.
It is handed it to me and he goes like this.
So he technically arrested me for trading and then he traded with me.
Yeah.
1990 is when that happened.
That was pretty crazy.
It was fun to see all that shit though.
Right before it fell.
Did you see like lines in this treat for food or anything crazy like that?
Yeah,
I'm not crazy.
Well,
yeah,
we,
I saw linens.
Uh,
we went to Red Square,
Square Lenin's tomb.
Um,
we went to some smaller little donkey villages.
Uh,
went swimming in the Nepa river right close to where to Nobel was like 50 miles
from Chernobyl.
So,
um,
but yeah,
there was definitely tell it was definitely some poverty going on here and
there,
but not,
not to the extreme that you hear.
You know,
I didn't see like these lines around buildings or for toilet paper or anything
like that.
But you know,
that's what it was.
Communism was on its way out too,
so it wasn't in the worst part of it,
but it was definitely an experience.
I was 18 when I went over there.
There's a picture of me in Red Square and I'm,
I got acid washed jeans,
I've got a bugle boy t shirt on and I'm wearing a fanny pack with deck shoes and
I'm just doing like this.
So that was fun,
man.
Yeah,
that's gotta be a hell of a flight too.
Right?
How long does it take to get the ride?
We went to Germany first on a layover there for like three hours,
Frankfurt and then Gow so young.
I couldn't even tell you how long that thing was.
It's been a long time.
Probably seven now.
That is an interesting country to me.
It's always been an interesting country because it gets so fucking cold there.
They're hard people.